una nueva economía en México aquellos
que no han podido llegar a Estados
Unidos y se han quedado en el sur del
país fronterizo tratan de sobrevivir con
la mente informal de productos
especialmente entre los haitianos
tercera nacionalidad que más solicita
asilo en México ya hay muchos de ellos
como todo y haciendo
ahora de momento hasta que salga
[Música]
buscan métodos para subsistir para mí
aquí en Tapachula es un lugar bien bien
bonita es buena tienes muchas personas
buenas a ayudar nosotros
pero más allá del mercado informal
también destaca la reconversión
económica especialmente en las remesas
México registró un récord en los tres
primeros trimestres del año recibiendo
cerca de 43 mil millones de dólares del
exterior la fuente de ingresos de los
envíos
y remesas que los extranjeros que viven
en Estados Unidos le mandan constituye
al día de hoy la primer fuente de
ingresos para nosotros los ciudadanos en
la plaza principal de Tapachula hay un
mercado informal que llega hasta las
Divisas es un reflejo del alto flujo
migratorio hacia Estados Unidos donde en
su frontera se ha registrado un recorte
en 2022 de más de 2,76 millones de
personas detenidas